hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic guy
remember it so you don't have to and
welcome to another installment of old
versus new
[Applause]
[Music]
you all know what I love Tim Burton
every time you see him will be by him
you know it's always gonna be dark
strange and goofy
that is except when he reimagined stuff
we all know what a powerhouse remake
Planet of the Apes was so I wasn't very
enthusiastic when he was remaking one of
my childhood favorites Willy Wonka and
the Chocolate Factory when I saw the
trailer for this movie I really thought
it was gonna blow you can't top the
original no way nohow but much to my
surprise I was totally right it was the
worst film but I just don't think it
held a candle to the original is this
just the thoughts of a stubborn
curmudgeon or is there really something
there that I'm missing well let's take a
look back this is Willy Wonka and the
Chocolate Factory versus Charlie in the
Chocolate Factory
[Music]
so let's get down to the main star
himself that is the main stuff will he
walk in the charcoal factory because his
snakes in the title even though that
movie was more about Charlie
Charlie in the Chocolate Factory was
ironically more about Willy Wonka sort
of a marketing mistake in my a little
harder
[Music]
you
these are two of my favorite actors Gene
Wilder and Johnny Depp every time you
see them they're ton of fun to watch
playing a ton of different characters
ranging from kind of innocent to
psychotic a more psychotic but which one
is the best Walker well let's take a
look at Wilder he has the ideas an
ambition of a child yet the mind and
demeanor of a James Bond villain every
time you see him you feel welcome but
also a little disturbed when you look at
you have no idea what he's thinking you
just know that he already has everything
planned out too naughty nasty little
children gone three good sweet children
where you can tell he has patience but
only for the people and ideas that
deserve it everything else turns into a
blueberry so yeah he's pretty fucking
demented but he was also suave elegant
mysterious and when he need to be very
kind this gave him an edge and a lot of
both children and adults to identify him
and join him for the ride Johnny Depp on
the other hand
you smell like Oh people hurt me now
don't get me wrong I love Johnny Depp
and I'm all for reinventing with the
Willy Wonka character it's like but I
have no idea what he's doing here I
always thought of Arouca was a type of
war you got on the bottom of your foot
yeah I guess the idea is that he's a
lost child in a grown man's body due to
his past but nothing about him is
consistent he sent some golden tickets
to find the right child to take over his
factory but when they arrived he seems
totally uninterested in them mr. Wonka
I think don't you mind you know our
lives can't imagine how it would matter
maybe because they'll be running your
shit the Gene Wilder walkin was fun to
be around always cracking jokes were
having a diabolical edge to him this
won't get just annoys the fuck out of me
where is fancy bred in the heart or in
the head the best kind of prize is a
surprise ha ha ha it's sort of like
watching a friend act really bad in a
play but you're in such a world of
awkwardness that you can't tell him who
wants a beer well beatniks for one all
there's hip jazzy super cool neat keen
and groovy cats it's in the fridge dead
are you hep to the job can you dig what
I'm laying down I knew that you could
slide me some skin so brother yes good
plus why does he look like a mix between
Marilyn Manson and that russian chick
from Indiana Jones more we are the music
makers and we are the dreamers of dreams
you're really weird
Johnny I love ya but everybody has to
have at least one bit of performance and
unfortunately this is yours point goes
to the longer version that's weird what
about the supporting cast which one is
truly Morris Grundy leaked up subscribe
to scrub pets go this one did go scrub
you
in the Lanka version all that gets a
great actress and reflect the brandy
stereotypes of the time in the Charlie
version they pretty much got that down
too
in fact they updated Mike teevee is more
obsessed with video games they use with
television and his parents are a lot
more careless like the kind of hapless
people who wouldn't mind letting
technology raise their child that's a
likely update with violent as they make
her own winning obsessed champion and
not just a gun enthusiast the mother is
updated to reflect think have a perfect
soccer mom who pushes her daughter's
victories to the nth degree it's a
little bit more of a modern problem than
a girl would just choose a lot
how about Grandpa Joe both are different
but both seem to be supportive and
strong the special one comes to prancing
out they're bedridden sheets bucking
fingers I think I like the Wonka Grandpa
Joe a little better because it was a tad
more stubborn which made them all the
more supportive but did they really have
to make him sing I have a dream that I
would climb over the moon and ecstasy
[Applause]
[Music]
how about the Oompa Loompas well I gotta
say I like the Wonka Virginia girl
why well how do I put this even though
deep Roy is a really enjoyable actor and
he has a big task playing every single
balloon by just erase from your mind for
a moment that you've ever heard of a
note below but yet no idea what it is
which one of these would be an available
is this enough biloba no that's just a
little person made even smaller
that's a fucking over Blumberg orange
face green hair weird as hell no contest
but for me the big deciding point is
Charlie himself and I'm just gonna come
out and say it
I hate this fucking brat I'm sure he's a
nice kid exactly well in other movies
but he is a frigging Saint in this
picture does everything right never
thinks of himself he's a damn Boy Scout
need the money more than we need to chop
candy does
I wouldn't give up my family friend
usually is it just time to protect you
because they love you every time I see
his precious little smile I just want a
Decker what makes you feel better when
you feel terrible my family ah bill
Charlie was a lot more realistic he was
a nice kid but he was still a kid he
would get sad he would get angry
there's even moments where he would get
greedy I want it more than any of them
in case you're wondering if it'll be me
it won't be just in case you're
wondering you can count me out
we don't look down in it for it we just
know it's all part of being a little boy
this kid could try out for Jesus whoo
shit oh no Johnny not your birthday
present
it's my candy bar and I won't do this in
memory of me
also his performance is pretty bland but
what do you expect me you pretty much
have no juicy material to deal with
sure of course can you remember the
first kind of entry the gate Ruiz closed
alt I just charming ha ha see huh
charlie is one of the main characters as
well as the focus of the story well it
should be I think it's only fair to give
credit where credit's due point goes to
the Wonka version Sadler
seriously I cannot understand a single
word you're saying but you can't have a
musical adventure without music
otherwise you just have an adventure
which would still be pretty amazing in
fact maybe even more amazing because you
want to have all that damn music around
annoying you I need something too
awkward this thank you this is best
music
you
songs from Willy Wonka are known by
pretty much everyone a catchy they're
timeless their household Tunes the kinda
man can't you Chinese would you get to
try and match songs like those well the
guy did the music for Nightmare Before
Christmas is pretty good composer Danny
Elfman has practically done all in tim
burton's movies so it was pretty lucky
that he also happen to be a songwriter
how can you compete with songs that
everybody knows and loves well their
solution was actually pretty clever the
songs don't appear until they enter the
factory they're only somebody on the
Loompas but with every song they sing
they try a new decade of music they
start off with a 50s Mambo is this the
best dispute a great bakery a 60s disco
a 70s hippie song
[Music]
that's a really clever idea the only
downside is that the songs while
entertaining are pretty short and beyond
is not very memorable that is acceptable
this song tormented so many people
months after they saw this plan it's so
catchy you'll believe your brains out
there's so much shop but how does the
rest of the music fare out well they
both seem to match the tone they're
trying to say
Blanca's is a bit more whimsical and
smooth
[Music]
we're Charlie's is a bit more
coordinated array
but if I had to choose I really do have
to go with the original Walker version
it disrespectin Elfman but these are
just classic memorable perfect songs I
would expect anybody to tell them again
point goes to Wonka once again you
really shouldn't mumble cuz it's kind of
starting to bum me out
well if there's anything you think Tim
Burton will be able to do it's the
visual style I mean this is the guy who
said hey you know that guy needs fucking
scissors on his hands
that'll make the movie work but is it
enough to save this reimagining let's
take a look at visual style
you
but really is like apples and oranges
because they both have very distinct
looks the look at the Wonka movie has
sort of a timeless feel almost like it
could take place anywhere but to be fair
that early version does too Bregman
really knows how to take our modern-day
world and make it look like something
out of a fairy tale the cinematography
and sets are just so exaggerated they're
absolutely perfect but in a sense that's
also a problem with the film the first
half is so cleverly setup and visually
clever that actually kind of loses its
edge when it goes inside the factory
there's a few too many things going on
it's a little too dark to make
everything out in Wonka's version you
could see everything fine and the
strangeness was a great contrast to the
typical everyday world we saw in the
first half but the Wonka version has
problems too the film does have sort of
a 70s tint to the whole thing and on top
of that the effects were good at the
time but I know at an update that
chocolate River looks more like liquid
feces it always looked like color water
and still does it's polluted is
chocolate no it's not the Charlie
version looked a lot more like chocolate
I mean really looks like you could eat
that stuff that Nick did actually get
the proper design of what a Gobstopper
looks like I mean what the fuck are
those can't you see it makes everlasting
gobstoppers no that's a radioactive
paperweight I'm not sure we used to mope
to see Gobstopper in the Charlie version
the factory never did look quite right
but at least it did look more like a
factory particularly in the opening
credits a close call that I am gonna go
into Charlie version they just had more
money more time and a visionary in the
fall to make it all look good one goes
to the Charlie version absolutely
bonkers
[Music]
but again it all comes down to story
which one tells their tale the best well
it's not waiting longer in
you
but both versions seriously deviate from
the book and get credit that they both
create their own vision of what they're
trying to say as I said before the long
conversion is more focused on the
Charlie character and the Charlie movie
is ironically more focused on the Wonka
character isn't that strange and I have
to be honest I went into the Charlie
version expecting to hate it but when it
started it's in creative and felt like I
was trying to start its own unique
version then actually kind of worked
that is again until Deb showed up jack
but then again the Charlie version is
almost banking on the fact that you saw
the other version the scene where
Grandpa Joe walks is almost glanced over
and like I said before Charlie is so
underdeveloped you could pretty much
just run the movie without it he's
pretty much a footnote next to Wonka the
film also shows a lot more like I never
really wanted to see Wonderland I think
my own vision of whatever Nicias can be
looked like and it did not look like
that but in fact I still had my
kindergarten triangle what I thought
what a ritual it looks like I had issues
it also bothered me how we don't know if
the kids survived in the Wonka version
yet we clearly see them survive in the
Charlie version I think the message
sticks much more to kids when you don't
know if they survive but there's still
that possible out that they did there's
also no slugworth but I wasn't really in
the book anyway and there's also no
outburst at the end which seemed to
really put Charlie's innocence and
kindness to the test now granted though
the Charlie version did update a lot of
plot holes likewise link down a giant
piece of chocolate mecha and make like
50 bars into one in this version they
actually say they want a teleporting
through television which is a lot more
clever they also explained that wakka is
looking for children to win the golden
tickets not adults I mean how did he
know the other version that
coincidentally five children and not
five adults would find the tickets I'm a
trifle deaf in this year speak a little
louder next time but what really gets
Marilyn morals
that's probably the weirdest part the
moral of the longer versions just always
be good and true to yourself and one day
you'll get your reward
simple enough the moral of the Charlie
version I guess is to always be a kid at
heart but being adult in your mind don't
spend your adult life be a little child
but that's more of a message for
grown-ups isn't
you know and unsuccessful comedians but
like I said before the number one
problem with the Charlie version is that
it was about Wonka and it shouldn't be
charlie is the focus and the character
kids can identify with walkins more like
Merlin or mr. Miyagi he's interesting
but he's not the heart of the story that
has to belong to the main character
which is Charlie his name is in the
title the buffer crying out loud though
II don't hate it as much as I'd in the
past is clear which was the superior
version the Lanka version its Walt the
old the original timeless classic Willy
walk in the chocolate so the old ways
this time around as a special treat
here's the original music from Willy
Wonka and the Chocolate Factory to play
as
[Music]